SCP-035 Vs SCP-173.
The evil Possessive Mask vs The murderous
Sculpture.
These objects are a lot less inanimate than
they should be, but are they evenly matched?
The biggest advantage that SCP-035 has over
173 is the fact it doesn’t have a neck that
the Sculpture could squeeze or snap, meaning
that 173 definitely couldn’t kill the Possessive
Mask.
However, given that SCP-173 doesn’t have
a traditional mind, body, or face, we can’t
really know for sure whether SCP-035 would
even see The Sculpture as a desirable host.
A fight between these two may just result
in the somewhat hilarious sight of them both
just sitting around, not moving, in a room
together.
We’ll call it a draw.
Really!?